good morning Hank it's Tuesday today's
video is like plato's understanding of
the human soul it comes to you in three
parts part one the small matter of
giving away more than a million dollars
so Hank the 2015 project for awesome
raised more than 1.5 million dollars
total we don't know the final shipping
cost for the perks yet so I can't give
out final numbers but today I do get to
announce the winning charities heck I
don't even know how to communicate my
excitement about how well the project
for awesome went this year except to say
that I am like cheese doodles guy
excited about it yeah yeah god I love
cheese doodles guys so I turned the
first half of the project for awesome we
raised more than a million dollars with
the help of some matching donors to be
split between Save the Children and the
UN's refugee agency and then all the
money raised during the second after the
project for awesome goes to charities
chosen by the nerdfighter community via
voting at projectforawesome.com
so the following 10 charities got the
most votes and will each receive $25,000
grants NaNoWriMo which encourages
creative writing and gives writing
resources to schools and libraries see
against malaria Foundation the harry
potter lives which turns fandoms toward
activism this star won't go out which
provides direct support to families who
have a kid with cancer or another
serious illness Liberty in North Korea
which assists North Korean refugees and
fights to expose the human rights abuses
their water.org which provides
sustainable clean water solutions to
people around the world she's the first
which provides educational opportunities
to girls in the developing world Planned
Parenthood which provides health care to
women in the United States and action
against hunger which works to end hunger
and malnutrition worldwide and then Hank
the next 10 most voted charities will
receive smaller grants but still more
than $10,000 those include lava made
Doctors Without Borders the Malala fund
uplift Direct Relief not forgotten the
Great Ormond Street Children's Hospitals
so paid charity water and the American
Foundation for Suicide Prevention so
that's where all the money is going
thank you for donating again all the
charities were decided by your votes at
projectforawesome.com so thanks for
voting also you can find more info about
the charities in the doobly-doo below
including a playlist with project for
awesome videos about each of them hard
to hack our mom's artist friend Connie
Bostick has made the greatest New Year's
card of all time and I wanted to share
it with you it's called we must live in
joy through the sorrows of this world no
real story there just a great New Year's
card part 3
hey guys this is my final blog brothers
video of 2015 I must ask nerdfighteria
for very important
questions to be addressed in the
comments below on what would you like to
see more and or less of on vlog brothers
next year - should the rules change 3
should the schedule change and 4 are you
seriously going to punish me because my
video about refugee camps in Ethiopia
was longer than 4 minutes you horrible
hideous monsters I tried really hard to
frame that question in a non-partisan
way I think I pulled it off heck I'm off
to go play FIFA's the AFC wimbledon
wimbly wombly so you can find that over
at youtube.com slash hankgames where
Hank doesn't play games happy new year
Hank I will see you on Friday